we're definitely not the only ones
who've noticed the sparks flying between
zendaya coleman and tom holland the
spider-man co-stars might just be an
item and we've got the clues to prove it
from flirting to date nights to body
language we've got it all down pat watch
until the end to find out which
celebrity's mom might have accidentally
outed the couple you look really pretty
and therefore I have valued no dinner
with the Colemans most of the time you
only go out for supper with someone's
parents when you're dating them
so when fans spotted Tom Sandhya and her
parents at Bobby vans Central Park south
back in 2017 jaws started hitting the
floor to make matters even more
convincing onlookers reported that Tom
seemed to be charming her parents
they're always together Sandhya and Tom
are both highly successful people who
are constantly on the go yet for some
strange reason they hardly ever leave
each other's side obviously filming the
spider-man movies ensured that they'd
spend a lot of time together but their
relationship is far from being the
typical co-star friendship most co-stars
spend so much time together during press
tours and events that they keep their
distance when permitted but not Tom and
zendaya instead they hang out with each
other's friends go swimming and spend
loads of extra time together
Tom's all about relationships Tom and
Sandhya have been rejecting dating
rumors since spider-man homecoming first
came out what are you hiding Peter
Sandhya has stressed that they're just
friends but we're not exactly convinced
Tom Holland is a super-sweet and good
looking actor do you think he'd be
dating girls left right and center
but according to Elle magazine Tom's
very single at the moment to add fuel to
the fire Tom explained that he's
definitely a relationship person but
we're thinking that he's really just as
india person Zendaya's super private
when it comes to her love life Sandhya
is a very private person in fact it's
hard to pinpoint who the actress has
dated in the past due to her secretive
nature in 2017 Sandhya talked about
having been in a
mitad relationship from 2012 to 2016
however she never disclosed to she was
dating despite they on pointing a finger
at her longtime close friend and fellow
actor Trevor Jackson so it's safe to say
that if anything's going on between Tom
and zendaya she wants to keep it a
secret and she knows just how to do it
they share a special bond if there's one
thing that's so obvious it hurts
it's that Sandhya and Tom share a very
special bond in fact they're so close to
each other that they tease and poke fun
at one another during an interview
zendaya disclosed that she had to grow
into her big head just like Tom had to
grow into his ears the look on his face
says it all their relationship is solid
and they're constantly teasing each
other and making goofy faces at one
another what do you guys think is this
love or is this love the tagging
incident it's the 21st century guys so
if you're under 30 years old you know
Instagram like the back of your hand so
many fans weren't convinced when zendaya
blamed the tagging incident on Tom not
knowing how to use Instagram on May 9th
2019 Tom posted a pic of him and his
co-stars but for some reason he tags
India's name right on his crotch but if
you look at Tom's older posts you'll see
that he's never failed at properly
tagging someone before we're not buying
it zendaya Tom's got 23 million
followers and Counting so he definitely
knows how to use Instagram single and
not ready to mingle if there's one clue
that's just staring us right in the face
it's the fact that Tom and Sandhya are
both in the prime of their lives and
single sure being a celebrity can make
dating a challenge but most people their
age are either dating someone or
mingling at the very least but when it
comes to Tom and zendaya there's
strictly off limits if tom is truly a
relationship guy then he would have been
in a relationship a long time ago we'd
buy their friendship if one of them was
dating someone else but it looks like
they're secretly committed to each other
she's worried about him it's perfectly
normal to worry about the people you
love especially when they're putting
themselves in harm's way during an
interview with MTV News Sandhya opened
up about her concerns about Tom's safety
zendaya went on to explain that Tom's
Spider Man suit is a full-on one-piece
that he often exhausts himself with sons
then they explain that she's scared that
he'll get sick and Cho she took things a
step further by saying that she gets
scared all the time
hmm sounds like a concerned girlfriend
to us Tom's first celebrity crush
another major hint that Tom and Sandhya
are an item was dropped during a pop
buzz interview the interviewer asked Tom
who his first celebrity crush was and
Tom went on to say damn even though it
wasn't true was the ever so people Tom
Holland trying to check his basis it
sure looks like it
Tom's inclination to say Zendaya's name
might have been an attempt to prevent
his secret girlfriend from getting
jealous Tom soon revealed that he was
only joking on the low but the most
convincing argument of all time has
everything to do with sky Jackson's
mother spilling the beans
it looks like the former Disney Channel
stars mother kya kool might have
accidentally outed the couple online
when a fan commented on house and Dan
Tom weren't a couple
kya cleared things up by posting yes
it's true they've been on the low for a
while however her comment was soon
deleted and revoked sounds like someone
got a phone call from zendaya so are the
co-stars dating or not tell us what your
verdict is in the comment section
subscribe to the things for more fun
videos about your favorite celebrities
movies and TV shows and don't forget to
give this video a big thumbs up thanks
for watching we'll see you next time
[Music]